why is everything bullied
oh well uh for two reasons uh one is
that we don't really know the true
reasons for why we do things so we think
that um we can just introspect on our
minds and just and and the true reasons
for why we do things just just comes to
the surface uh we have full access to
all of our underlying motivations and
goals uh but there is a lot of research
Decades of it in fact that shows that
that is not true what we're really doing
when we're explaining why we do things
is we're coming up with a nice sounding
self-flattering story a story that makes
us look good that makes us look
competent and rational and virtuous
but we really don't know the truth about
why we do things
um and uh the other reason is that we
are just as in the dark if not more in
the dark about why other people do
things
that is uh we don't have access to their
inner monologue or to the the sights and
sounds that make up their Consciousness
uh and yet we are uh often just as
confident about the reasons we give for
other people's behavior as we are about
the reasons we give for our own behavior
um so if you combine these two facts
that we don't know why we ourselves do
things and we don't know why other
people do things and you combine those
two facts with the fact that most of
what we talk about ultimately pertains
to the reasons why we and other people
do things well then most of what we talk
about is [__]
how is that different to lying
well uh lying is when you uh
deliberately misrepresent the truth so
you know what the truth is and you are
intentionally saying something different
bullshitting is uh is when you don't
really know the truth or when you don't
really care about the truth the truth is
just not your concern it's irrelevant
you're trying to pursue a social goal
whether that's looking good whether
that's persuading someone whether that's
uh you know making yourself uh look
virtuous or competent or rational uh or
getting a better deal in a negotiation
that's the goal not truth
um and you might occasionally say true
things uh in service of that goal but
whenever you do it's by accident it's
not by Design the truth just happens to
conveniently serve your purposes in that
particular instance but when it doesn't
serve your purposes you uh neglect it
ignore it downplay it minimize it
Etc so really what bullshitting is is a
kind of Truth free
communication you don't care about
what's what's true and it's just not uh
at the top of your mind it's not your
your top priority sometimes I guess it
may end up being that the thing that you
are bullshitting about may also end up
being true you might kind of like close
your eyes throw the darts and it hits
the bullseye on the truth dartboard and
like hooray like I told the truth today
um this can be quite disempowering I
imagine for many people to hear that you
you don't truly know yourself you don't
truly know other people
the things that you do believe that
you're doing and not the you're not
doing them for the reasons that you
think that you're doing them uh
how do you not become a despondent black
pill that throws himself off a bridge uh
given the fact that you've basically
told everyone listening
from your Insight of expertise as a
trained academic in the world of
psychology that truly understanding
yourself and the people around you is a
hopeless thankless impossible task well
I don't think it's impossible I thought
if it was impossible I wouldn't be uh
researching it I wouldn't be writing
about it I wouldn't have a sub stack
called Everything is [__] so it must
be possible for at least somebody to be
right about why we do things and you
know it just so happens that I think I'm
the one who's right I think we have I
have the real reasons why we do things
uh and I think those reasons are backed
up by a lot of interesting uh research
from psychology and from evolutionary
biology and Game Theory
um so I wouldn't say that the search for
the true reasons for a behavior is
hopeless
um but that doesn't make it any less
um
flattering I mean it doesn't
I mean I
the thing is it's still kind of a bummer
because uh even if we can say what the
true reasons for our Behavior are those
aren't going to be the reasons that we
like
um they're not going to be the ones that
make us look good because obviously we
have an incentive to uh give uh better
reasons for our Behavior than the true
ones so finding out the true ones uh is
going to be a bummer necessarily it's
going to make us look bad it's going to
make us feel uncomfortable and it's
going to disrupt a lot of the status
games that we play with one another so
uh you know it's it's a bummer but it's
a double-edged sword I mean you can use
it to attack your Rivals and attack you
know status games that you see other
people playing that you don't like it's
going to be much harder for you to to
call out the [__] in yourself and to
call out the uh the [__] and the
status games you're playing uh but you
know ultimately I think that uh a
clearer understanding of ourselves is
going to lead to good outcomes I'm not
sure what the exact causal pathway is
between knowledge and good outcomes but
I'm pretty confident the the pathway is
there in Robert writes why Buddhism is
true which I know that you're a fan of
as well he's got this great quote that
says uh ultimately happiness comes down
to deciding between
the discomfort of becoming aware of your
mental afflictions or the discomfort of
becoming ruled by them I know that
happiness is something that we may end
up getting uh uh into later on as well
but I I do think that largely he's true
and I asked uh Jeffrey Miller this I've
asked David bust this
um
I've talked a lot about evolutionary
psychology on the podcast over the last
two to three years it's been a pet
Obsession of mine I find it endlessly
fascinating and it seems as close to me
as uh a discipline that appears under
the hood of human
um motivation to work out the genuine
reasons for why we do things and it
doesn't always get that right um but it
it tries to get close to it but as many
of the people listening to the show and
I have realized it can become
disheartening to realize that you are
essentially a marionette being played by
the puppeteer of this ancient Millennia
old programming uh you know anybody
that's taken the proximate versus
Ultimate reasons for Behavior red pill
understands that even the best reasons
that you can give for the things that
you do are not the reasons why you do
them uh so the the rabbit hole descends
uh very deeply for the people that I
have force-fed a lot of ep2 over the
last whatever uh thousand days or so how
would you advise them to
ameliorate or absorb the insights that
they learned that are fascinating from
the world of evolutionary psychology or
even behavioral genetics and stuff like
that too
um how do you deal with this the the
fact that it's both interesting and
enlightening and can make you feel less
agentic and less sort of sovereign over
your own behaviors as well how do you
avoid that making you feel too
despondent
it's interesting uh the way I avoid it
is by going one step even deeper and
analyzing the despondency itself and
where that comes from and uh and seeing
that the despondency itself is another
kind of uh marionette string that is you
know being pulled by my uh deeper
biological instincts so if you think
about what that despondency is well it's
it's the feeling that
um your Collective projects that you're
engaging in uh your goals that they're
being exposed in some sense
um and uh and and all of a sudden their
value has decreased
um because I mean this is something that
I've written about recently uh we cannot
play a status game if we're all aware
that it's a status game because as soon
as we become aware of it then we stop
getting status for playing it
um because wanting status is a cue of
low status we don't like status Seekers
we don't like social climbers we call
them Vain and narcissistic and insecure
and selfish and Petty uh and um we don't
want to be seen in that way so this
creates a paradox and that in order to
seek status we cannot be seen as seeking
status we have to somehow get status
without making it look like that was the
goal right uh and when I say it's the
goal that can be
destabilizing it can threaten to make
our status games that we're all playing
together collapse and we hate that
that's scary because if they collapse
then we could lose all our accumulated
status that we've gained over many years
of playing this game and practicing it
and honing our strategies right that's
very scary and very threatening uh and
you know there's not much I can say to
make it any less scary
um it is scary but
I think the upside of it is that being
aware of the status games we play uh and
the logic of how they work can help us
choose between them a little more wisely
uh some status games are clearly better
for the world than others some status
games lead to better outcomes
um I ult I think status is ultimately or
sorry I think science is ultimately a
status game
um you know scientists are you know
competing for a Prestige uh just like
any other human and any other industry
right they they want to get that
citation count up they want to impress
their peers and show off their uh their
formidable intellects
um and uh I think if we understand that
that's ultimately how science works that
empowers us to shape the institution of
science so that scientists are
incentivized to uncover more true things
and if we're aware of how other
institutions work we can shape the
incentives to uh create better results
and if we're you know young or having a
midlife crisis and haven't yet decided
what status game we're going to play
understanding how they work is going to
help us choose the status game that is
ultimately going to lead to better
results for all of us and so if we can
make us all more enlightened uh more
aware of the games we're playing we can
be wiser stewards of those games and we
can choose more wisely among those games
I think the bottom line is there is no
environment there is no situation in
which more ignorance
I can would create a better outcome you
there are there are uh troughs of
Despair whatever that thing of like
Enlightenment is there's a path of
Enlightenment and there's the the trough
of Despair and the value of difficulty
and the the peak of believing you know
it before you descend back into the
valley of Despair again
um but there is no situation in which I
can imagine more ignorance would
actually be uh uh would be useful for
this so I want to get into seeing
whether we can squeeze the spiral of
status and seeking it and then undoing
it and then learning it again to see if
we can actually get to the point of
doing something which is good for us and
why we do what we do but before we even
do that like why is status so weird and
random just high level why is it like
that
well it goes back to what I was talking
about about the fact that uh we cannot
play a status game while being aware
that it's a status game so there's an
inherent fragility at the heart of all
of our status games there's a paradox
there and the Paradox is we cannot know
what we're doing while we're doing it
right
um so uh in order for us to successfully
uh compete for status with one another
um the secret cannot get out that we're
competing for status right so if we're
engaged in a self-important serious
intellectual conversation uh it cannot
be revealed that what we're doing is
participating in an intellectual pissing
contest you know if you and I found out
that we're just you know we're pissing
around and trying to show off our our
impressive intellects well then all of a
sudden we would lose all of our
motivation to play the game we would we
would not be having the conversation
because the opportunity the potential to
gain status from it would be gone why
why is it why is it the case that
thinking about the game destroys the
game
uh well because as soon as we think
about the game we realize that it is a
game and we realize that we're status
Seekers and then we can no longer gain
status because we don't like status
Seekers
why don't we like status Seekers for a
number of reasons
um one is that we see them as selfish
um they they tend to prioritize their
own status seeking over the well-being
of others that's one reason
um
another reason is that uh they're
probably low status if if you want
status that means that you don't have it
right so that's another reason uh we
don't like them because we see them as
disingenuate uh as manipulative as
dishonest as willing to lie or backstab
to raise their own status
um
so uh for all these reasons uh being
seen as a status Seeker is going to
lower your status
that's that's the paradox
um and so because we cannot let that cat
out of the bag that makes our status
games uh inherently fragile and prone to
collapsing
under the weight of their own
recognition right
yes so you you've got this quote in one
of your articles where you say we
pretend we don't care about status as a
way of gaining status so the the point
being that not only is the game undone
as soon as you stare in the mirror or
say Beetlejuice three times and then
status all descends on you um you can
also be more flippant or more casual
about the byproduct of status you gain
from doing the thing that is state of
seeking whilst not recognizing it by
playing it that way you gain even more
status by avoiding looking like this
Machiavellian manipulator that's
Wheeling his way to the top exactly yeah
so if I you know buy a Prius because I
care about the environment that's a very
different story that you could tell
about me than me buying a Prius to show
off my virtue right it's the same
behavior in both cases but the intention
is different the goal is different
um and uh insofar as the status seeking
goal is revealed it cannot be achieved
so if I am just you know buying Priuses
and uh you know
avoiding plastic and and doing all these
environmental things just to look good
and just to show off how great I am well
I'm not going to get status for doing
that my heart has to be in the right
place in order to get status in order to
actually look virtuous in order to
Signal by virtue I cannot know that I'm
signaling my virtue and you cannot know
that I'm signaling my virtue because if
you knew you wouldn't you wouldn't award
me virtue so I understand the why I
can't know why other people shouldn't be
able to detect but why is it important
that you yourself aren't aware of this
is it just because the best way to
deceive others is to believe it yourself
that's the idea yeah as George Costanza
once said uh in Seinfeld it's not a lie
if you believe it yeah I think we have
to convince ourselves of these things in
order to be more convincing to others
yeah that makes that makes a whole lot
of sense how is it the case then that in
2023 virtue signaling and performative
empathy are two of the biggest Trends on
the internet that to me on its face just
seems like totally transparent
what's happening there have you
considered virtue signaling or
performative empathy and and kind of
some of the
um facilitations that modern technology
has enabled People's State are seeking
and how it's molested and perverted that
yeah so uh social media is a really
weird and alien form of socializing that
we have invented uh and it's it's alien
in the sense that it's uh ex it's like
uh shouting your opinions on a
loudspeaker to a you know to hundreds or
thousands of people uh you know
socializing in the ancestral environment
and small-scale hunter-gatherer
societies
um you weren't really talking to more
than a few people at any given time uh
so the fact that you can tweet something
and have hundreds or thousands or even
millions of people read it uh is a
really novel situation and it makes the
reputational consequences of our
activity on social media way uh more
important than they were in ancestral
environments so in some sense our
psychology is not equipped to deal with
this and the other uh weird thing about
social media is that there's a
permanence to it so if I tweet something
it's going to be really hard for me to
get rid of all evidence of that tweet on
the internet right uh the same thing
goes for posting something on social
media or saying something on a podcast
like the information is going to be
present on some computer somewhere right
and that is of also a really weird thing
you know if you're socializing with a
bunch of hunter-gatherers uh and you say
something offhandedly the fact that you
know most people are probably going to
forget that or or not know exactly what
it was that you said that is to your
advantage right because if they might
misremember it you might be able to
dispute what their interpretation was of
what you said you know there's a little
bit of ambiguity and room for
negotiation uh in a free-flowing
conversation where memory is the only
means of recording it uh but where we
have computers recording it uh all of a
sudden that that that makes our words
like set in stone uh and undeniable and
I I can no longer like wiggle out of
something I said on the internet 10
years ago like it's written in stone I
can't change it uh and I can't negotiate
I can't say oh you're just remembering
it wrong you know like that strategy is
not available to me uh so it's those two
things I think the permanence and and
the huge audience we have that are
really alien to us and I think they're
uh messing with our psyches in really
profound ways going back to the
fundamentals of how status works it
seems to me that The Sweet Spot is to
somehow find a way to Signal a trait
whilst concealing the fact that you're
signaling the trait but the problem here
is that the signaling of the trait is
ultimately the thing that's going to get
you status so you can't completely
conceal it because if you completely
concealed it then it wouldn't achieve
you any status in the first place that's
right how do we balance this yeah uh
well the the key is the word completely
there uh so if we completely concealed
it then we wouldn't do anything or say
anything right we wouldn't leave the
house we wouldn't be going on podcasts
or writing sub stack posts
um the trick is to conceal it maybe 90
of the way
you know so that you know only the
really attentive person is going to pick
up on on the fact that uh that you're
great you know or uh uh and and the
thing is they cannot pick up on the fact
that you were trying to look great they
have to
pick up on the fact that you are great
so you have to make your signal look
like a cue so it's probably important to
backpedal on the distinction between
signals and cues so a signal is
something that uh is intended to convey
information right so if I say hey look
at me that's a signal in evolutionary
biology we talk about signals as being
something that evolved for the purpose
of conveying information
a cue is something that is not intended
to convey information in an evolutionary
biology we say it's it evolved but it
the the reason it evolved was not to
convey information so for example if I'm
sweating a lot or if I'm stammering a
lot during this interview that's a cue
that I'm nervous but it's not a signal
cues are important in that observers can
use them as valuable sources of
information to guide their behavior uh
but they but they weren't intentionally
emitted uh by the by the person right
um so the thing is we're constantly
looking for valid cues about a person's
character right
um but we're not looking for signals
because we know that
signals uh are are uh can be dishonest
in some sense we know that there's an
incentive to fudge and distort signals
to make ourselves look good right and so
we really we want to
we want to catch someone in in their in
their true form as if they weren't being
watched you know uh we want to gain deep
insight into into you know what they're
what they're really like and how they're
really going to behave when no one's
looking right and so that's the game
that we play as we try to make our
signals look like cues we try to uh make
it look like we're we're going to behave
this way when no one's looking uh when
people are looking or when we think
people are looking or or maybe we're not
even aware of it at all but but in any
case that's the game we're playing
because we're ultimately looking for
Reliable signs of a person's character
so that we can count on them uh to
behave in certain ways when we're not
judging them when we're not looking them
uh when they might have the opportunity
to backstab us uh we we really that's
that's the key thing that we're looking
for and we want to try to signal that
without making it look like we're
signaling that uh and in some sense we
may not even know ourselves that we're
signaling that it may be better for it
to be unconscious
it's got me thinking about the uh common
held piece of dating advice which is
look at how they treat serving staff and
waiters when you go to restaurants and I
think that that
I might be right in saying that that is
something people think of as a cue that
is indicative of a signal that is
indicative of something that's deeper
it's you know it's like the sweating or
the stammering that it's seen as such a
normal everyday interaction that it
should be people that they're least
encumbered right this is their true your
true self comes out on YouTube between
10 p.m and 11 pm at night and when
you're dealing with a serving a serving
staff person or a waiter in a restaurant
that's got your order wrong like those
are the two times that you're at your
truest
um you're most transparent and I I'm
thinking about different examples of
that what about you you wrote this great
article on your sub stack that everyone
should go and check out about status was
there anything that popped up that you
thought was a particularly interesting
example of uh the weird ways that status
can get hijacked that people use it and
abuse it and and kind of get confused by
it yeah
um
so uh actually it was an interesting
piece in the New York Times uh I was
reading um about how wealth signals have
become concealed
um so I don't know if you noticed this
but in succession uh one of the main
characters was wearing a baseball cap
but if you actually zoom in on the cap
and do some research you find out that
the cap is like twenty thousand dollars
or something like that right so it might
look like a normal baseball cap that
sort of conveys his you know working
class nonchalance and yet it is just a
covert uh status signal uh and then the
article goes through many examples of
these things that are designed to look
cheap and mundane and commonplace but on
closer examination are actually wildly
expensive uh and that sort of what we
call that in game theory is a buried
signal that is only some people can can
uh detect the signal so wealthy people
are going to know that it's that it's
expensive but ordinary people aren't
going to know so you're trying to Signal
the trade to a specific type of audience
whom you really value uh while maybe not
caring so much about other audiences so
that's that's an interesting uh example
of it and the other interesting example
of how these status games work is um
what I call sacred values and I think uh
what a sacred value does is it allows us
to play a status game uh without
realizing it's a status game and that
basically what they are is they're their
cover stories their narratives that we
all share and we all tell ourselves
about the true reasons why we're doing
things and they're often altruistic and
Noble uh and idealistic uh and overly
abstract
um so that they can potentially
accommodate uh any anything we're doing
um you know stuff like authenticity
self-actualization happiness equality
Justice honor
um these are all sacred values that are
uh designed to protect our status games
from collapsing uh and and the way they
uh protect our status games is by uh
appearing as though they are the
opposite of status so insofar as status
is uh Petty and small-minded and selfish
uh sacred values are high-minded and
altruistic and larger than ourselves we
want to try to engineer the concept to
be as distant from status as possible so
that it's not confused with status
because as soon as it's confused with
status the status game collapses
um
so that's what a big part of what I
think sacred values are and and I think
if you look at any cult any tight-knit
group their status hierarchies are
bathed in sacredness uh sacredness is is
saturated uh in their culture the it's
not even a status hierarchy it's it's a
it's a Justified great chain of being
you know it's you know these people are
are genuinely wiser and more virtuous
and that's why they have power over us
you know we're not submitting to a
dominant Alpha the alpha you know the
person is is shepherding us toward
wisdom and Transcendence
um and so I think uh having a nice
sacred ideology or belief system allows
a status game to really persist and
remain stable for a long time uh and uh
and protect the members of that
Community from from the kind of
collapses that I'm talking about what do
you say to the people who reply eat [__]
David on a and integrity and telling the
truth and Ultra and empathy and hard
work and all of this stuff those are
axiomatically good things and you trying
to pull the wool from my eyes and say
that this is actually secretly me trying
to get laid uh you need you need to get
in the sea
um I would say that you know I actually
have some sympathy for for that reaction
so I'm not saying that because these
sacred values are [__] that they're
necessarily bad
um I think you know some [__] is
better for the world than other [__]
you know uh if you look at science you
know it's it's bathed in sacred values
of knowledge and wisdom and
disinterested truth seeking
um and and in some sense they're those
values are [__] uh but in another
sense it's really good that those are
the values that are you know being
pursued or at least you know being
pretended to to be pursued
um because uh the institution of science
needs those values in order to persist
and in order to uncover genuine truths
um for the same reason you know uh
status games around success in business
or Athletics or whatever
um they can motivate genuinely good
behavior uh and yes you could say that
uh at the end of the day it's motivated
by by status but
uh you know at some point you got to
shrug your shoulders and just say that's
human nature and we got to deal with
that and we got to accept it uh and if
we want to change the world for a better
we for the better we have to recognize
that because if we want to create a
better world there's no way to do that
other than by changing the social norms
which ultimately means changing what
gets us status and what doesn't like
that's that's what social change is at
the end of the day it's changing what
gets us status and what doesn't and if
you don't realize that that's how social
change Works you're not going to change
anything and so I think being realistic
about how this works is going to make us
wiser uh uh both consumers of culture
and producers of culture yeah what
should people take away given that
you've just spent 20 minutes
deconstructing potentially what
everybody is motivated to do their
behaviors due to
how should this inform the way that they
see the world and move forward
yeah
um I think it can give you
um a little more compassion and empathy
honestly
um and that you realize that everyone
out there is just as scared and insecure
and and self-conscious and lonely as you
are and that's ultimately what's driving
their behavior
um and you know it can help us you know
have a little empathy for the people we
might disagree with politically you know
we we like to think that they're in
pursuit of some you know evil Wicked
agenda but really they're just they're
in pursuit of the same agenda we are you
know they they want to be loved they
want to be praised and respected uh and
that's ultimately what's behind them and
you know we have the same human nature
as them uh and the more we understand
that I think the more we can better work
together with those people uh under the
recognition of our own shared Humanity
yeah I uh a couple of things that
definitely most people that did heinous
awful despicable things in the past
believed that they were doing good
there's very few people who actually do
evil things in full recognition that
it's evil because that's not the way
that we're wired what would be the
motivation to do that there has to be
something on the other side of it
um and yeah I think the
acceptance of the fact
that status games aren't going away
ultimately it's very difficult to even
conceive of a world in which genuine
altruism bereft of any sort of
um reflective glory on the person the
the altruist uh how what that would even
look like how that would even work and
and how you would motivate someone to do
it so the bottom line being that you
need to work with the world the way that
it is as opposed to the way that you
would have it be it's not this first
principles pure rationality this is you
know long term is a meets effective
altruism thing bro like that's just not
how we're wired and the the way that we
are wide and the most effective way to
do this is to say okay we have kind of
like the thermodynamics of human
behavior going on here yeah we need to
be able to play Within the rules of this
game and there's another another sub
stack post of yours which I absolutely
loved which was to do with desires our
desires and how they work so what is it
what is it that most people don't
understand about how desires work do you
think yeah uh the thing that people
don't understand and perhaps aren't
willing to admit because it's it's
uncomfortable to admit is that our St
our desires are relative uh they're
competitive we don't just want to get an
education we want better educational
credentials than our Rivals you know we
don't just want people to like us they
want we want people to like us more than
they like other people we don't just
want to have opinions we want to have
better opinions and smarter and Wittier
opinions than other people
you know the list goes on I list I think
like 10 or 12 of them in the post but uh
the idea is that uh uh we're constantly
comparing ourselves to other people
um because ultimately we are evolved
creatures we are products of darwinian
natural selection and biological Fitness
is an inherently relative concept so I
could have you know all the food I want
you know I could I could have a nice a
nice house access to water you know I
get everything I want but if my
neighbors are doing way better than me
uh then that's not going to matter
eventually my genes are going to dwindle
uh relative to the genetic uh
representation of my neighbors right so
ultimately from a darwinian standpoint I
want to have higher Fitness than my
rivals than my competitors that is the
only way to maximize my genetic
representation in future Nations so it's
con it's comparative it's competitive
natural selection is the competition
between the stuff that's selected and
the stuff that's not selected which
means that we our brains are collections
of the stuff that was selected right
which means that that stuff had to be
better in some sense than the stuff that
wasn't selected which means that our
desires are ultimately revolving around
being better than our competitors being
better than our Rivals I do think that
it's to a significant extent built into
our nervous systems
um and there's a problem
um I I don't think that uh we can we can
change that fact I think I think it's I
think Evolution wired us to uh uh out
compete our Rivals because the most
competitive Among Us were most likely to
out-compete their Rivals and were most
likely to pass on their genes to the
Next Generation right we are descended
from the most competitive and
successfully competitive of our
ancestors we weren't we're not descended
from the uncompetitive losers right
um but of course the irony is were
descended from uh competitive people who
successfully concealed their competitive
nature because in order to win the
competition you cannot look competitive
right we compete to reassure each other
that it's not a competition yeah okay
and there's a problem yeah so the
problem is that we can't all get what we
want right if what we want is inherently
relative to what other people have then
we cannot get what we want at the same
time right uh and that that is the
problem so that what that means is that
we're just going to keep competing with
one another until the end of time we're
never going to achieve some Utopia where
there's no more social hierarchy or
where everyone is happy for all time uh
because no matter how much stuff we get
we're always going to be comparing
ourselves uh and our stuff to our
neighbors and the stuff that they have
right and we could all be you know have
Intergalactic time traveling uh pods uh
we could have you know immortality
elixirs and yet we're still going to be
jealous and envious of our neighbors who
have better immortality elixirs and
better Intergalactic time traveling pods
than we have right it's never going to
go away there's no um there's no happy
ending to the human drama we're just
going to keep jockeying for status until
we obliterate ourselves or go extinct
but
there is some hope I don't want to be
completely depressing here I know that I
tend to lean in that direction with my
sub stack and I'm trying to work against
it but I think the one way we can sort
of outsmart evolution
is by uh success successively out
competing older Generations
so if if status and living standards
keep rising from generation to
generation
then uh we're all better than somebody
and that's always going to be the
previous generation and that's great
because ultimately what we want is to be
better than somebody it gives everyone
what they want but here's the loophole
is that the previous generations
actually want future Generations which
include their children and grandchildren
to be better off than themselves it's
and then if it's in their darwinian
Fitness interests uh for future
generations to to do well right so
everybody wins when we when we out
compete our elders you know when we say
Okay Boomer that is that is the slogan
of human progress right
we we want old people to become more and
more irrelevant uh yeah
that's brilliant so I I've got it in my
head um Gene twangy's work uh on
Generations looked at how from whatever
it was the Gen x's and the one before it
the
not the boom what was the one just after
the Great Depression anyway that group
all the way through and she talks about
um this uprising of the middle class the
ease of access to cars the ease of
access to households etc etc and then
you see this pivot and you can even see
you call it intergenerational
competition Theory you can even see
the reverse of this at work or when this
goes wrong and I think that Millennials
and specifically gen Zed have a b in
their Bonnet because they look at their
parents generation and they see that
they were able to buy a house by the age
30 and they were able to support a
family just on one living wage and they
were able to afford two cars and two
holidays per year on on a normal job uh
and they don't think that that's the
case and yeah
there are
children who are upset that they're not
doing better than their parents but
there are very rarely parents who are
upset to see their children doing better
than them and I think that that seesaw
asymmetry uh explains your ICT idea yeah
absolutely I think you can explain a lot
of the problems we're having by the
inability of some segments of the
population to out-compete their elders
um and if you look at you know uh the
research on uh what's called deaths of
Despair
um it's it's primarily happening among
groups of people who think of themselves
as failing to out-compete their Elders
or among Elders who view their children
as failing to out-compete them
um so wow that's one as well that
parents of of dispossessed children yes
yes
um so I think what happens is when we
fail to uh compete our elders and we're
all on the same playing field well then
the zero-sum competitive tragedy of The
Human Condition catches up to us and now
all of a sudden we all have to be better
than each other again right we were all
happy when we could all be better than
old people right we all win you know but
if we're not better than old people then
oh no who are we going to be better than
now we have to compete with one another
you know we have to we have to form
coalitions and tribes to to get more
stuff than other people and all of a
sudden the competitive ugliness of human
nature kicks in so I really do think
that the the key to Prosperity is is
intergenerate successful
intergenerational competition it might
be the one thing that is preventing us
from killing each other yeah I I dropped
my insight about this uh to do with the
fact that because of this comparative
game that I think is relatively
inescapable and definitely at a macro
level individually you know enough
meditation psychedelics might be able to
dissuade you of this but that's that's
not going to work for the populace I
said to Sam Harris I think it's a reason
that Universal basic income
fundamentally doesn't work because you
end up flattening the income hierarchy
down we've got robots to do everything
now and we believe that everyone's just
gonna lie under a tree totally blissed
out doing [__] poetry and and playing
the acoustic guitar
what's more likely going to happen is
that people are going to find weird and
wonderful ways to accumulate status
again they're going to start this
competition game all over again okay so
we've flattened income you've read will
stores book uh the status game where he
talks about that uh group that has yams
they they build but grow the biggest yam
and then they give it to their enemy
um like it's just going to be a society
of people growing massive yams or or
crocheting or whatever it is that's you
know an arbitrary not that much more or
less arbitrary than accumulating
resources or buying a Ferrari or a Rolex
or getting boob job but you know largely
just a different status game and I think
that it's it's one of the problems that
you get when you look at um at Ubi and
also
uh if you're right and I feel like you
probably are and this intergenerational
competition theory is one of the
domesticating forces that keeps people
feeling uh happy and insane that I might
not be doing better than my next door
neighbor but I'm doing better than my
parents on average across across a
civilization if we are about to face a
population collapse in which you're
going to have negative GDP growth for a
sustained period of time and we can't
offset that with Automation and AI
you are locking in
uh you're locking in pan generational
recession right and I think that you
know for all that you can say
objectively living standards should be
able to be ameliorated because we've got
all of the Automation and the blah blah
and it's like yeah but how do people
feel they're doing like what's the
mental state of the
2060 born child
compared with our generation now what
what how do they how do they feel about
this and if they look back and they see
a golden era that we think is some awful
version of the actual Golden Era that
was the Boomers and they look back and
they think you it's despondency all the
way down yeah no I I agree with you
um in some sense uh and that we cannot
get rid of our status games and I think
a lot of toxicity comes from the
misguided notion that we can that we can
achieve a status free Utopia I think
that's a dangerous idea uh and a
fundamentally unrealistic idea I think
you know uh you mentioned will store's
book the status game he's got a
wonderful chapter on the rise of
Communism uh and how it was a
competitive dominant movement that uh
appeared to be against competitiveness
and against dominance you know it was an
egalitarian anti-agalitarian movement
that created enormous balances enormous
imbalances of power and inequalities of
power and Status among the more you know
the loyal members of the regime got all
these benefits and Privileges and perks
you know the disloyal members of the
regime were excluded marginalized
sometimes killed uh subtype sent to who
forced labor camps so if you think about
the Communist Utopia where everyone is
equal it is in fact the opposite where
it has some of the starkest and ugliest
uh and most brutal forms of inequality
known to our species
so I certainly agree with you that
um uh utopian theorizing is misguided
um I agree with you that uh getting rid
of our status games is impossible
um and I also agree that it's and in
some sense we need to choose among the
status games that are the best for our
species and insofar as status games go I
think competing to offer people goods
and services at more and more affordable
prices is not that bad of a status game
you know like it incentivizes us to do
things that are generally helpful and to
give things give things to people that
they generally want so I think markets
are a pretty good status game as far as
status games go and I think that they
are uh sadly underrated uh by a lot of
people on the political left
um that isn't to say that they can't
co-exist with with the basic income um
perhaps they can as you know as as a
sort of safety enough for you know uh
the direst forms of poverty but um I do
think that we need to appreciate the
benefits of markets as incentivizing the
right kinds of behavior and I think
often times the reason why we don't like
markets is because the status
competition is too out in the open for
us yeah it's too icky you know we don't
like to be seen as greedy or as uh
materialistic uh and so in order to
signal that we're not greedy and we're
not materialistic we often oppose
capitalism and oppose markets and we try
to create anti-consumerist consumer
cultures where we consume
anti-consumerist books and and t-shirts
and and podcasts
um but at the end of the day I think
it's it's it's misguided and we need to
appreciate that that markets are are one
of the one of the engines of human
progress I'm not going to say it's the
only engine but but um it's it's a
pretty damn good status game that we
should uh keep playing as long as
possible what do you say to people who
claim that their fundamental goal in
life is to be happy
uh I would say in the nicest uh and most
polite way possible that that is
[__]
um you know I'm not trying to be mean
but I do think it's [__] uh I don't
think we want stuff inside our heads if
you think about the way that Evolution
programmed our brains it doesn't make
any sense for evolution to program us to
want stuff inside of our heads it makes
sense for evolution to program us to
want stuff in the world stuff like food
sex status resources right the things
that correlated with biological Fitness
and ancestral environments those are the
things that we are wired to want and to
seek out
um we don't want the idea of that stuff
we don't want the story of that stuff we
want the real stuff in the real world we
don't want to be misguided or mistaken
we don't want to be deceived about it we
want the real stuff
um so I find the idea that we evolve to
one happiness to be fundamentally
evolutionarily implausible I don't think
it makes any sense especially when you
think about what happiness is from a
functional evolutionary perspective and
in my post happiness is [__] I give
a theory about what I think happiness is
uh and what I think it is is a a
predictionary her it's when your brain
expects something to be at a certain
quality and it ends up being better than
you expected right the food is tastier
than you expected the sex is better than
you expected you know uh you you thought
that the paello would taste like [__]
but it ends up tasting amazing
um you thought that everyone would roll
their eyes at your dumb joke and
everyone's rolling on the floor those
are the types of things that give you
happiness they are unexpectedly good
outcomes and what happiness is is your
brain recalibrating itself in light of
an unexpectedly good outcome so when uh
when you have a prediction error your
brain sort of lights up and kicks into
gear and does all these things to
reprogram yourself so you can get more
of that thing in the future so it um it
plays the happy scenario in your head
over and over again analyzing it uh
figuring out what might have caused the
good thing to happen what you got wrong
it's revising your beliefs updating your
expectations shifting your priorities
all these things are happening uh when
we experience what we call happiness
but that doesn't mean that we want to be
happier that's not the thing that we're
seeking when you play a guessing game
you're not looking to maximize the
number of times you hear the words
getting warmer no you want you want to
guess the thing that's the point of the
game if you guess the thing on the first
try without any getting warmers you've
won the game you've done a great job
right you shouldn't uh cry that you
failed to get into getting warmers
because the getting warmers are
irrelevant they're just there to help
you they're there to push you in the
right direction and I think happiness is
ultimately there to push you in the
right direction but it's not the thing
we actually want it's not the thing
we're seeking uh and even if we did want
it uh we couldn't get it because it's
impossible to get right something that
is intrinsically unexpected is
impossible to pursue pursuing happiness
is like planning your own surprise party
right you can't do it
so I think in fact I think insofar as
people do pursue happiness or try to
pursue happiness as a status seeking
tactic uh they are setting themselves up
for depression and misery
um I think we oftentimes what we don't
we don't want to be happy but we want to
appear happy we want to appear like a
happy person like we're well adjusted
we're healthy we're healthy we're
self-actualized you know we're nice
we're happy go lucky
um that's what we really want we want to
convince other people that we're happy
and even convince ourselves that we're
happy uh and perhaps convince ourselves
that we really do want to be happy and
we're the type of person who seeks
happiness as opposed to status or
Prestige or something that's ultimately
what we're seeking but insofar as we
seek that we're making ourselves
miserable because we cannot get the
thing that we're seeking
um and so I think a lot there's a lot of
toxicity around the pursuit of happiness
and self-actualization I think we would
do well to stop pursuing happiness
because the more we pursue it the less
of it we'll get what's better to pursue
instead
[Laughter]
oh man I guess our [__] sacred
values uh
assuming that we picked the right ones
yeah I mean it's it's a great question I
wish we had uh a say in the matter I
don't know that we do have much of a say
I think Evolution has chosen our desires
for us and we just we do the best we can
to to fulfill them and we can't really
do anything else I don't I I'm skeptical
of the idea that we can remake ourselves
uh and and fundamentally redesign our
basic desires uh I think that's a pipe
dream
um the best we can do is choose among
the desires we have that Evolution gave
us and try as best as we can to
prioritize the ones that are uh better
for us I guess better for the world
um you know ones that we can that we're
more proud of
um you know I I have a 15 month old
daughter I try to prioritize that desire
over my other desires and that's you
know it's it's an evolved desire you
know my DNA is shaping me to to care for
my Offspring but I don't care you know
I'm still proud of that desire I still
want to uh fulfill it and uh and that's
that does that's a desire I can get
behind and I think you know if we if
we're more wise about all the desires we
have and choosing among them I think we
can choose better ones or at least shift
ourselves a little bit towards the
better ones you've got a number of Hama
blows uh that's a list of problems with
the idea that humans want to be happy so
I'm going to read a few of these off
just in case people were not feeling too
completely broken yet we know that if we
savor every moment every smile every
meal every ray of sunshine we will be
happy yet we Savor maybe one percent of
those moments we know that if we
appreciate what we have from the roof
over our heads to the clubs on our backs
we will be happy yet we appreciate maybe
one one percent of what we have good
news makes us happier than bad news yet
we consume way more bad news and good
news even though we can't do anything
about the bad news and even though there
is plenty of good news available anger
feels bad yet when we're angry with our
loved ones we think about all the times
they made us angry which just makes us
angrier why don't we think about all the
times that made us happy we can delude
ourselves into believing pretty much
anything the Earth is flat the world is
run by a cabal of satanic pedophiles Etc
yet we never deluded ourselves into
believing that everything is perfect and
wonderful as it is if we were actually
pursuing happiness we'd be very good at
it by now given our many years of
practice yet studies show that we suck
at it we're incredibly bad at predicting
how happy things will make us or how
long happiness will last there are vast
bodies of scientific evidence that could
stop us from sucking at happiness like
positive psychology the science of
Happiness yet most people aren't very
interested in this research because it's
kind of boring we work too much and some
of us literally work ourselves to death
even though we're well aware that this
makes us unhappy having a child makes us
less unhappy and more stressed and we
know this yet we do it anyways often
multiple times we maintain relationships
with [__] even though it would be
clear that we would be happy without
those [__] in our lives we
constantly beat ourselves up but almost
never give ourselves compliments And We
complain about Twitter on Twitter
well you know it sounds so much better
when you read it Chris it's the British
accent um but yeah you know all of those
it's so right and you kind of lay out a
bunch of objections oh well it's hard oh
well I I want to do it or I try to do it
even though I can't do it
um you know there are a number of um
potential barriers that people would put
in place about why it is that they would
want to do that and they don't manage to
achieve it either mean to do it even
though they're not good at it
I don't know what replaces it though you
know
peace of mind is
the closest approximation I found to
something that's scalable as like a
mental state that I think that people
should really really try and optimize
for I think meaning is probably not far
off as well but meaning can actually be
perturbed by peace of mind
um so you know from everybody that I've
spoken to and it it often gets into just
this semantic argument of like what do
you mean by happiness exactly and what
do you mean by meaning exactly and is it
how long does happiness last so on and
so forth
um
but it's my belief that
if ultimately what we want is to live a
life which in retrospect we are glad
that we lived a combination of peace of
mind and meaning peace of mind
facilitates everything else because if
you don't have peace of mind
no matter how good the life is your Dan
Bilzerian in a rocket ship surrounded by
Playboy models like guess what you're
having a [__] time so that doesn't
matter your moment to moment experience
of the world is going to be tarnished
and if you don't do anything which is
Meaningful the second that you do begin
to reflect on whatever it is that you've
done you're going to be ashamed of it or
at the very least you're just not going
to be proud of it because I think you
know meaning is doing the thing which
you tomorrow would have wanted you to do
right like that's that's a nice
conception of it yeah yeah that was a
that was a good a good choice for me to
make I'm glad that I did that and that's
why you know when you are faced if you
are on a diet if you if you're you know
tempted to cheat on your partner or
whatever it is asking yourself what
would me tomorrow want me today to do is
such a lovely reframe it gives you a
little bit of distance it makes you
project you out into the future
but between those two things like I
don't really know what the [__] else
we're doing here like what what what
what are we doing here we're playing
these status games but ultimately our
desires aren't our desires their desires
that are manipulated by a variety of
other things that we didn't get to use
well hopelessly at the mercy of these
Millennia old Marionette strings that
are playing with our different
preferences even if we do manage to do
enough evolutionary psychology to learn
why we do the proximate reasons for our
Behavior the ultimate reasons for our
Behavior come and smash Us in the face
and then happiness the one thing that's
supposed to be this Universal good that
we were all chasing after maybe isn't
actually that scalable and how would
Evolution have programmed it into our
brains in the first place so yeah lots
of lots of nails and coffins I feel yeah
you know Chris I wish I was better at
poking holes or I sure was better at
telling news stories than I was at
poking holes in our existing stories
because I'm clearly bitter at the whole
poking than I am of of the the telling
of the news stories maybe that's
something you're better at than me uh
but yeah no it's something that uh I've
struggled with
um what do we do uh if not pursue
happiness
um well I I like your idea of pursuing
meaning
um what I think meaning is is ultimately
long term I mean sorry to bring it back
to the depressing evolutionary
psychology but what I think meaning is
is long-term Fitness value so we have
things that maximize our Fitness in the
long run with uncertainty and with
continued effort and persistence and we
have things that maximize our Fitness in
the short run uh immediately so things
like you know food in your mouth right
now that makes you happy or makes you
feel pleasure but caring for your child
that's more of a long-term Fitness
maximization strategy you know your
child isn't going to become a healthy
adult all at once it's going to take
many years uh and a lot of patience uh
and a lot of um kindness and and support
from other people
um the same thing goes for starting a
social movement forming a tribe that's
going to be a successful tribe or it's
going to compete other tribes that takes
a long time takes a lot of effort and
persistence and it might it might cause
you pain in the short run you know my
daughter can sometimes be a pain in the
ass uh but what meaning does is it helps
me weather those storms it helps me put
up with with those temporary pains and
discomforts and keep my eyes on the
prize of the long-term goal of raising
her to be a healthy adult the same thing
goes for other meaningful projects like
you know forming a stable community
forming a strong tribe uh cultivating a
valuable skill that gets you a lot of
success that's something that takes a
really long time and can be meaningful
for people
um forming a really good uh trusting
relationship with with somebody can be
meaningful uh those things are good I
like those things I think we should
pursue those things but the thing is we
already were pursuing those things and
when we you know we never were pursuing
happiness it was just a story we told
ourselves uh to begin with so it's not
so much what should we pursue now that
we can't pursue happiness we were never
pursuing happiness to begin with we were
already pursuing uh the goals that we
already had right we're already trying
to form good relationships and be good
parents or you know cultivate a valuable
skill or or whatever and now it's just a
you know making us more aware of those
goals that we actually have
right that's that's what poking halls in
our [__] does is it it makes us more
familiar with the stuff we're already
doing and the stuff we already want
um so uh the question of what to pursue
instead of happiness I think is the
wrong question
the right question is what story are we
going to tell ourselves now that the
happiness story is [__]
uh and unfortunately I don't have a
great answer I mean maybe you can come
up with a better answer but I think
there are plenty of other better stories
available we can tell ourselves you know
we're we're trying to seek the truth
we're trying to understand ourselves
we're trying to make the world a better
place we're trying to be effectively
altruistic and perhaps we're trying to
see through the [__] of effective
altruism to make it even more
effectively altruistic there are plenty
of uh good stories we can tell ourselves
uh and I think we just got to choose
between them the conflict is where a lot
of discomfort arises so when people
believe that they should feel happy and
they don't and you you're battling
against this
I would be interested to know if we had
an anti-happiness happiness movement
um that kind of help to relinquish
people from chasing it I wonder whether
more of it would happen first off I've
seen some evidence that people who
actually work on happiness or that they
purposefully try to be happy they read
books on happiness they result in having
lower levels of well-being moment to
moment in yeah in self-reports
um
but also the the the the pleasant
emotion that you get when you do things
that you know are good because you've
designed them in advance to be good
because you know that spending time in
nature makes you feel better than
spending time on the couch therefore you
spend time in nature and oh [__] is a
byproduct of doing this I I feel this
sensor well that that's suspiciously
like happiness that thing that's just
happened to me is roughly proximate to
What happiness is supposed to be so yeah
yeah I wonder whether um but again you
know we spiral it one one layer deeper
and naval's got this great quote where
he says uh desire desires are a contract
we make with ourselves to being happy
until we get what we want
and I don't think that that's
necessarily untrue that as soon as you
posit an ideal you then begin to compare
yourself to that ideal and up until the
point at which you reach it there is a
sense of dissatisfaction
um you know if you want the car you are
ruminating about the car you're
researching about the car you see it on
the street all the time you work and you
work and you work and then you get it
and then you just flick onto the next
one so it is a uh an agreement that your
level of Life satisfaction will be
capped up until the moment at which
another thing happens and you reach it
and then very quickly you do that that
ratchet of ever uh difficulty increasing
uh achievement doesn't seem like a
scalable solution for call it what you
want well-being human flourishing new
demonia whatever
um I think there needs to be something
something a little bit more
uh reliable than that something a little
bit more scalable than that that you can
find day to day yeah so the question
isn't you know what are we going to want
because we cannot choose what we want
Evolution has already chosen that for us
the question is what are we going to
pretend to want you know what are we
going to socially reward ourselves for
appearing to want
right that's the the one thing that we
have control over we have control over
the stories we tell ourselves and those
stories are powerful those stories
actually do change our Behavior right
um so what story are we going to tell
um
I like your peace of mind idea and I
think you know in some sense we do want
peace of mind if if you frame peace of
mind as the feeling you get when you get
what you want and you no longer want
other things then yeah I guess we do
want that because that's just a
different way of saying we want what we
want you know where we we want to get
what we want right uh and nature is an
interesting example
um I I do think that being in nature is
another evolved preference we have you
know we you know we evolved from nomadic
hunter-gatherers who you know went from
place to place and camped out at
different places and settled down and
nicer habitats that were more Lush and
full of life and easier to navigate with
you know water sources and animals and
uh navigable landmarks like mountains
you know so I do think we have evolved
appetites for for beautiful natural
environments and I think the modern
world has interfered with that desire to
a great extent and I think it is perhaps
responsible for a lot of our unhappiness
is our inability to be in nature because
that's basically that's the place where
we're supposed to be from an
evolutionary perspective and it does
make us feel good I think when you get
relaxed and you feel a peace of mind
when you're in a beautiful environment I
think that's your brain telling you hey
take it easy spend some time here yeah
you know maybe move here you know you
know we we
meaning your genes we want you to uh to
stick around here as long as possible
this this is a good place I remember I
remember reading uh an article a while
ago that explained why
vast spanning views finally I've got the
house of my dreams and the balcony looks
over the perfect Vista of in the
distance and so on
um is that
do you think that there would be a an
evolutionary reason for that given that
we would have greater
um view of potential Predators potential
warring tribes risks prey etc etc is
that why we have this preference for big
Landscapes it's why you know no one very
few people very few people have a kind
of
messy bush
Thicket
image painting on the wall lots of
people will have a beautiful mountainous
Vista with spanning fields and a sunset
in the distance
yeah no I buy that I think they're
they're definite adaptive advantages to
having Higher Ground to overlooking a
vast landscape you have you know as you
mentioned strategic advantages over
potential Invaders you get to it's much
easier to navigate when you can see the
whole landscape in front of you it's
basically just like having a map splayed
out on the table you know and getting
lost was a major selection pressure for
our ancestors you know if you got lost
you're dead you can't find your tribe
you're dead uh and so being in a place
that's easy to navigate where you know
where everything is there are clear
landmarks you know where the water is
you know all the different animals there
you know which places are safe to hide
which places are safe to camp out I
think that's you know I I certainly buy
your your reasoning there good what
makes stuff interesting why do we find
things interesting
hmm well I think you might know where
I'm gonna go with this but I'll I'll
take you through the Journey anyway
um so you might think that we're
interested in stuff that's useful for us
yeah stuff that helps us make better
decisions live better lives pursue
happiness even or you might think that
we're interested in in the truth stuff
that's uh insightful and accurate that
reveals the subtle Contours of reality
really at the end of the day we're just
we're Seekers of knowledge you know we
we want wisdom you know that's that's
what we're after when we're we're
clicking through blog posts and and
tweets
and Facebook posts were ultimately
looking to gain useful knowledge truths
about how the world works right that's
the conventional story
about the conventional story is [__]
unsurprisingly uh I don't think we want
any of that stuff or at the very least
it's very low on our list of priorities
I think uh too often we tell the story
about ourselves that we're the Smart
Ones in the animal kingdom that the
reason the human brain is so big is so
that we can use tools and build
impressive machines and Conquer nature I
think that story is wrong I think the
reason why our brains are so huge is
because our groups are so huge and we
need to navigate those groups I think
the human brain is a fundamentally
social brain I think the brain evolved
not for Tool making and practical
decision making but for gossiping
politicking rule following covert rule
breaking rationalizing uh self-deception
I think uh you might call us homo
hippocrites as uh Robin Hansen calls us
I think if you know if you reflect on
what you actually use your brain for
it's almost completely about people and
people related stuff right you don't
spend your time thinking about home
repair and and auto parts right you know
tools are a very small part of the the
stuff that occupies your mind uh most of
the time you're thinking about oh how
can I uh make this person happy how can
I resolve this conflict you're gossiping
or you're thinking about uh conflicts
with family members or you know you're
worried about some snide remark someone
made and whether they secretly don't
like you or or whatever like this is the
stuff that your brain is used for and if
this is what your brain is used for it's
hard to argue that your brain is
ultimately a rational tool making
machine it's clearly a gossip uh and and
rationalization machine that's really
what it's about it's about winning
arguments
winning social conflicts gaining status
uh and so once you apply that lesson to
what we find interesting you realize
that uh what we find interesting is the
stuff that fulfills our unflattering
social goals that we do not want to
admit either to other people or to
ourselves for example
I lost a whole bunch of them in this
post uh it's called you will find this
interesting uh for example uh we want
attention uh we are interested in things
that get us attention because when
people pay attention to us that makes us
feel smart and important and special uh
and so we are attracted to the
titillating uh the Gory the scary uh the
sexy uh the gross
um the paradoxical the confusing uh all
these things help us get attention uh
we're interested in things that uh
almost no one else believes so strange
beliefs weird beliefs counterintuitive
beliefs because if we can prove to
people that they're right well then we
get to look smarter than everyone else
so we're looking for for that uh for
those rare beliefs that help us gain an
edge over our competition uh you know
same thing goes for moral beliefs uh we
want stuff that makes us look morally
Superior to other people we want stuff
that casts our political Rivals and a
negative light uh that makes our
political allies look good we want uh
information that justifies what we were
going to do anyway or what we wanted to
do anyway we want to fit in we read the
news and and read about sports and
celebrity gossip not because these
things are inherently useful but because
everyone else is talking about them and
we don't want to be left out of the
conversation if you think about what's
true and useful you know the vast
majority of it is old and yet we're
obsessed with the news and I think that
goes to show that we're more interested
in being part of the conversation that
people are having than we are at finding
useful truths uh and you know the list
goes on we want to you know signal our
membership and and special clicks by uh
you know name dropping people that
proves that we're in the know and you
know mentioning books that only members
of our subculture would know like oh
capital in the 21st century only really
smart members of the intelligence will
know that one and that helps me connect
with fellow members of the intelligencia
while subtly excluding dumb dumbs who
aren't as cool as me
um so there's all these signaling games
we play these four you know these uh
these clicks we form the subtle acts of
exclusion
um yeah lots of stuff like that I go
into more ugly
I understand that so give explain to me
why then
our brains are so interested in [__]
like if they were involved evolved by
natural selection why do they seem to
function so poorly why they're not
actually trying to seek truth
well uh if you think about the truths
that we actually read about on the
internet uh almost none of them are
actually practically relevant you know
if you if you think about like you know
the policies that are going through
Congress like you're not going to be
able to affect those policies like you
can vote yeah but you have what a 1 in
60 million chance of swaying the
election like you can't really do you
think you can't do anything about the
the political uh events that are taking
place in your country and yet we're
fascinated by politics it's almost all
of what we pay attention to right which
goes to show that uh it doesn't make
much sense for us to care about what's
actually true in the political domain
because what's true or what's false
doesn't really affect us what affects us
is our social standing among members of
our community so yeah I might not
personally lose out if I support a
policy that makes the world worse but uh
if I support that policy and it gains me
status among my political allies well
then I I win right so I'm going to Care
way more about the status I get from my
political allies and I'm going to care
about whether the policy is actually
make making the world better and so uh
it really from an evolutionary
standpoint it shouldn't matter to us
what's true or what's false about these
abstract uh distant impractical matters
that we read about and talk about uh you
know we're not talking about you know
how to fix our toilets or like you know
how to how to do practical things in the
real world at least not most of the time
uh most of the time we're talking about
really vague abstract fuzzy political uh
matters that have no bearing on our
practical day-to-day lives and that's
where these social motives come to the
fore and dominate any other practical
truth-seeking motives yeah I was going
to say why is it then that we are so
distracted by those things why is it
that we care about Congress and and all
the weird [__]
yeah I think they help us fulfill our
social goals in a way that practical
beliefs cannot so if I think that
um let's say uh the sky is blue uh
that's not going to help me to
differentiate myself from other people
it's not going to help me signal
membership in a particular click because
everyone believes that this guy is blue
you know if I believe that there's
something wrong with my carburetor and
my car uh the other people aren't going
to disagree with that I can't be
I can't use that to gain status right so
they're really only a specific set of
beliefs that we can use to play social
games with one another uh and they have
to by Design be disconnected from the
practically relevant ones because if
they were if if we used our practical
beliefs to jockey for status and form
clicks well then our practical beliefs
would be wrong and we would [__] up all
the time in our lives so we have to
separate the intuitive practical beliefs
that we use to actually make decisions
from the vague area abstract political
beliefs that we use to form groups and
jockey for status and never the twain
shall meet uh
you know
and
uh that is by Design I think because if
they did meet uh well we'd make bad
decisions and we'd fail in our social
goals at the same time so we have to
have our cake and eat it we have to you
know intuitively unconsciously know
what's true for the immediate practical
decisions we make while at the same time
uh pretending to believe all sorts of
other weird abstract vague things to
Curry favor with our allies and with the
people we want to uh impress what is the
lesson to take away then is it the
interesting stuff is overrated and that
we should seek out more boring [__]
yeah basically uh I think uh that's
that's one of the lessons I I take from
it I think
um
we have this [__] idea of ourselves
that that we're you know high-minded
knowledge Seekers and I think that
it's healthy for us to see through that
[Music]
um
I think we often ignore
and neglect and look down upon the
boring person at a party or a boring
friend or boring family member we think
we're better than them because we have
access to more interesting tidbits you
know we've read the latest think piece
and therefore we're better than them
um
and I think this kind of
intellectual status game is increasing
our sense of loneliness and alienation
you know uh if we're trying if we're
constantly competing to be interesting
and we're looking for the most
interesting conversation Partners well
we're going to spend more time listening
to podcasts like this one to make
virtual friendships with uh people who
were who are who sound really
interesting instead of talking to real
people in the real world like our
friends and family members who might not
be as interesting but will offer us more
fulfillment and companionship than the
virtual friends that we try to I was on
board I was on board until I realized it
was going to reduce the listenership of
the podcast
sorry sorry Chris listen listen to this
podcast but not any of the other that's
right that's this is the only one that
is able to thread the needle between
evolutionarily what's adaptive and uh
ethically what is optimal David prints
off ladies and gentlemen David I love
your work uh everything is
bullshit.substack.com for your stuff uh
it's phenomenal everybody needs to go
and subscribe to that where else should
they go to harass you and find your
stuff online uh you can feel free to
harass me on uh Twitter of all places uh
the uh nadir of human happiness uh you
can find me at davidpintoff on Twitter
feel free to DM me if you want I'm very
friendly much friendlier than uh than I
might appear based on my beliefs
David I appreciate you thank you mate
thanks so much Chris it's been a blast
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe